you
so fond of her talk is many there are
girls computer-readable everything I
discuss I really wishes at a rebel
environment for moving there are many
demos to put it there at that oh so good
rates and then you have for questions so
before they start I'm just one see a
show against how do you put here who
this bride irony rails muscle good day
everyone and here it is piping hot I
have another okay a couple and grouper
library and your news I really young
fantastic
okay so I generally talk about scholarly
Python which is where it started that he
does anyone there was this scientist
brunette hair estate business and he was
working on my phone and here's what
working herself we had our print food
and wasn't he says after dinner so if
you voted precious lips together to meet
a better and this never wall for the
years until in 2009 the back and the
front end of the ripple was split and
this allows a rich we are denigrated GT
and a hybrid by men and because the
traps and one on this mine ended up this
foot allowed years later to create the
notebook which is a web environment
where there's website you take a coding
and send it over to the controller then
send over
colonel and defy the colonel evaluates
the energems result and the sword is
your lab the pudding and a multiple of
kernels so person afterwards they
created our back and forth and also hand
for it which is the one I'm talking
about ah salua cooking that so many
couple years old and not really that
much used it's really making by danielle
member and it could be the run try or I
of English but uh what the most in your
house you know and I'm that down so the
Dow I'm not do in the style of julia
child who who wrote The Art of French
Cooking 1960s and the way you and shows
positive tisha and nobody she worthless
that should have something for dairy
food and some food issues working out
wrong and she was talk about their speed
things up and he must've thought much
rice emulating hopefully so I'm gonna
start a movie console vitami of the
muscle large this is what it looks like
I can just
execute arbitrary would be come in here
on like a river irony or try session
instead of having individual lines
executed it's quiet results and you know
right Sultan and it's giving out of
water so so I can do something like like
this and that it will be available to me
in any other so in this case a previous
so it also inherits features of pride so
for example of love I can do stuff like
tap completion also has multiplying
cells so I can do things like
and it'll execute that this is actually
pretty hopeful when you do something my
favorites console right here first and
happy trails console though that's not
really the best way working in rails and
to that end I create some for my wrist
you can turn them up at first I Nelson
here I literally the rich content so you
may have guessed that this presentation
is actually a dopo itself and signature
go to a child here it's just an opening
okay Jacob file using a movie and then I
even opal be smarter to get the
home and figure out issue display as an
image in all the previous has to have
actually I Ruby cells but so here we go
there it's being marked down one down to
display I cannot convert you to convert
into Ruby code Jewish gangster all fail
for sin tax reasons back to market now
do business doesn't look quietly or I
will be no book is because I stood this
piece of HTML code here that's hiding in
a bar and then we comment that out
we'll get an app for that alright so for
records
so this isn't quite polished so I hear
me too loaded in this weird way i'm
working on a gem to get us working but
essentially what this does is it blows
the rail is consoled and not from
notebook so I started in this notebook
in in a demo great start sorry guys two
rails guy so I know that simple Hagen
articles and I someone also so hopefully
do so this makes the models available
just as he was going to be in a rails
environment but this does something more
so it's not it's just be able to make
believe the models you can also work
with the fuse okay so what kind / index
is a trail to you and to execute
good and now it's actually
executors as HTML now try an expert and
some are going to more complicated
things like this is a article session
it's been more complicated here let's
try / any of that so fails because says
and find that each from now question
articles indexed so pleasure look at
this
I can't Imran in further but as you can
see here this requires just add articles
to be present
so we just include them in vocals which
somewhere local it works
there we go now that HTML and that's
what's wrong with that
now have a few beers in the notebook i
use the several times to work with you
so we have a blush snap to get them up
to scratch mostly not with rendering
focus but just partials when I
controller and all those stuff works
pretty well so that's it for the demo I
guess I'll show you how to actually
start this up so let's let's go back to
the dashboard where all the notebooks
available close them
so this is running in the console so
once you have the IRB Jeremy we just
type every notebook if a little bit
consoles will show you the dashboard
where all the normal thing working are
available and we're going to turn the
number store it up these are notebooks I
say this file is on a disk so you can
commit it to first control or remove
them because they're kind of femur like
I can nail them around they've not
shared in the other people here going to
any viewer if this interesting I have
some instructions in how is actually
gets working descriptions for being I'm
really working are available on movie if
I and then to know if it were when I
rails is some of the vailable that the
hint about / a great house well so does
anyone have any questions
Oh
I definitely have that real simple open
minds own workflow that is investigating
the models as we have and doing a
hardware design and Anna go together
though he from I do you still use
Charlottesville in rego the profile
honestly
so reassuring so the FATA let's eat
locally is a JSON file and keeps track
of all the source code in a miss Camille
and animals keeps track of the output if
any other example in this line a truth
is an album and would you like that in a
case of the image and it has some codes
it and stores it a big wall well he was
I rehab as so I believe has ability to
run Ruby code as it is the ability
otherwise I'd say it's a gestation
theory because there's a lot of it and
willing to acknowledge i believe its
most difficult balance work and lost a
lot but even then it's very
full-featured having up having pride
working it gives it a lot of you
abilities so for example are surfing
argue that
right so you visualize data ah there's a
few standard Vipers are people doing
that but I believe you thought of words
would I you betta book and then there's
the other time d'you know surrender
likely headstone in two I will be no
book you can render a few other things
as well can actually I'm actually show
you
so this is a friend of scanner that I
Ruby notebooks example which I didn't
write but this is latex code and it's
being rendered as wait it out I can also
do some fancy dinner tables cry and a
lot more adjectives so new but works in
this case it's not working this happen a
lot installed but if you look on a solid
or under properly
I
well there's a library so you're naked
two different libraries they gotta
perform surgery cal versus themselves as
their why would be fine at versailles
renders road overhead and this I believe
is pretty much the same one the spot
python friend as a fluidity shoes Zoe oh
I almost beautiful because you're cute
sevilla 262 just never is a lot slower
than a thought little knot or program
for practice
so I decided in your browser but you
can't really ask set from outside ruby
is not is Ruby Valley in browser and
salsa olimpico gets a government gets
sent to that effect rubbish and sensor
is unity to the movie Colonel but they
were fighting the controller only allows
access to the firm from the local
machine you can actually so you can
relax it'll exist if you want to do that
there's some problem switches you can
float in the background to make it
available to more than just to see over
today 0 that's the area 00 but that
involves working and then you can set a
password on
if I asked to edit me this month machine
or sleep but even if it crashes the
colonel if I'm sorry right away if I had
this beforehand to demonstrate
abstraction it's not really really
wanted crashes with those sunglasses but
your story is very quick
so
I actually don't know how to cause it to
crash on purpose but we can restore our
purpose
here we go so then just you're starting
to turn on house back up again so then
execute code again starting to go can
you type exit yeah sure let's see if
we're still alive
well
sure so we push my side department of
place I go and it was right before so I
mostly use it to investigate so your
most things in to investigate our models
sometimes never run free pumpkin
previous to find out what actually
happened life and flesh is so oh great
Assad's against local there a good a
pretty large degree together ten lines
half a page wherever here is working and
then I'll it into the real star
selection box but our intention is that
in purpose to make this available
directly from the ocean so this will be
running arm on observer mission
introduction with a cessation all the
classes and get this so we have to do
this coffee peaceful
awesomeness I will leave your own
attorney mode it can so we demonstrated
so this is a I Ruby right return i
rewrite an internal and looks exactly
like this pet Python furniture mouth
look like I'm the question of the
advantage of this is or a problem
because all they're really measures that
are far in Python a nitrogenous courier
and are implemented by fri for a mouse
all right now thanks to enemy and if any
questions afterwards for us book
they did not coming on to me after he
goes off i think